so you dreamed this up sitting in a car
outside of your home here in Los Angeles
what was going through your mind you
know it was 4:00 in the morning and I
was coming home from a music video shoot
and just feeling like this can't be what
I meant to be doing but it kind of came
all at once in this phrase two women go
on a crime spree and but I kind of saw
the whole movie in one flash including
the ending yeah and then the studio's
passed on it good and you ended up going
to me me with it at the time actually
Kelly really wanted to direct it and you
know we talked about it and we talked
about how big of a movie we wanted it to
be here with me for a million dollars we
could definitely pull it off and five
million I was thinking yeah Ridley spent
another 13 on water trucks and myself
Ridley wasn't originally planning to
direct it at all
he thought he'd produce it right he was
afraid of two women in a car on a crime
spree didn't think it would be exciting
enough for him hence the water trucks
and hundred-mile I was backwards in the
gas station thing about the movie is
that it's so honest you know it really
doesn't pull any punches and you watch
these women turned from feminine
creatures into incredible heroes and and
they stripped themselves along the way
how much of that was in the script how
much what that was was what you and
Susan worked out and you're in your
wardrobe well my favorite part that I
remembered watching it was you know at
one point I end up wearing JT's
denim shirt and then later I had the
sleeve the sleeves are ripped off and
susan is like washing with the sleeves
and then she puts little strips of the
sleeves on her neck and and then I end
up with the trucker's hat I would all
that stuff was really fun I don't worry
I mean everything was in the script I
don't remember exactly but maybe some of
those little details were but that was
really fun for
and I think really really understood it
in some very deep way you know he really
wanted to make this movie and people all
along the way I'm sure suggested
changing the ending and I think in fact
you guys even tested at one point a
different ending but I actually when we
finally did do the deal with passe which
wasn't supposed to be distributed by
Warner Brothers I actually got it in the
contract that they could not change the
ending of the movie because I knew it
would be an issue because it always came
up meetings was just once when the car
was actually started to head down and we
got terrible ratings because everybody
thought it was too depressing so that
those are freeze-framed kind of there we
were okay it's always been a hard movie
for me to categorize from the very
beginning I don't really know what to I
call it an outlaw movie but it is a
comedy and reason I wanted to make it
funny is because women are funny and
they're funnier when they're alone and
you know and it's just I wanted to put
them in that world where they could just
so totally be themselves and the
stripping away of everything including
the makeup and all of that it was all
about starting them out how the world
wants you to be and you're pretty but
you end up as you are and you're
incredible so that was my point
fortunately I had Gina and Susan to make
it perfectly and I mean you know that is
something I will be forever grateful for
thank you
you
you